bien mon cher
François merci de de m'avoir invité
aujourd'hui euh je vous salue tous en
vos grades et qualités mais plus
spécialement vous le comprendrez mes
collègues sénateurs mais aussi les
membres de l'Assemblée nationale du
Parlement européen et tous les amis que
que je reconnais ici parce que je vois
évidemment beaucoup de de visages amis
alors quand François m'a appelé pour
m'inviter il m'a dit écoute voilà on
fait notre réunion avec les jeunes à
Guidel est-ce que tu accepterais de
venir et il m'a dit il y aura bien sûr
Jean-Paul Marc euh enfin il m'a cité
tous les amis ici présents je lui ai dit
en somme c'est une cousinade et donc
c'est bien volontiers que je me retrouve
ici avec vous en terrain familial et et
amis alors euh je crois que le temps est
compté je voudrais faire simplement
trois observations je voudrais euh la
première c'est ici nous sommes euh chez
les jeunes euh dire que nous avons un
premier impératif et une première
responsabilité et ils ont une première
responsabilité c'est de réinvestir le
champ démocratique de moins en moins
d'électeurs votent de plus en plus
d'élus démissionnent et singulièrement
ici dans le morbillan j'allais dire que
c'est quasiment un département témoin il
y a des milliers des centaines euh
d'élus qui démissionnent depuis les
dernières élections municipales ça s'est
jamais vu il y a une désertification euh
du champ républicain de la démocratie et
il nous incombe il vous incombe de
convaincre les jeunes et les moins
jeunes de le réinvestir c'est notre
responsabilité fondamental parce que
partout où la démocratie recule c'est le
populisme qui avance et donc c'est la
première des responsabilités que nous
avons et vous les jeunes en particulier
la seconde chose que je voulais dire
c'était que depuis les les dernières
élections
législatives évidemment vous avez
observé et Jean-Paul vient de le
rappeler il n'y a plus de majorité
évidente à l'Assemblée
nationale ce qui fait que le Sénat a
pris une responsabilité
particulière le point d'équilibre
institutionnel s'est déplacé en partie
au Sénat et il est de la responsabilité
du Sénat et singulièrement du groupe
Union centriste de veiller à ce que on
termine les textes comme on l'a fait
pour les retraites qu'on termine les
textes et qu'on fasse des textes qui
soient viables pour être votés par
l'Assemblée national c'est notre
responsabilité à nous sénateurs et je le
ferai avec tous les amis du MoDem ici
présents et je les salue notamment ceux
qui viennent d'être élus et vous me
permettrez de faire une mention
particulière pour Isabelle Floren qui a
été élue dans les hautes
scènes notre groupe notre groupe va
pouvoir se maintenir à son niveau le
groupe voisin de la majorité sénatoriale
vous voyez à peu près de qui je parle va
perdre environ 10 à 13 sièges ce qui
veut dire qu'il y a un petit
rééquilibrage qui n'est pas sans effet
et je crois que nous pourrons influencer
avec la sensibilité qui est la nôtre
évidemment la ligne politique de cette
majorité et en particulier sur le plan
européen cher tiierry breton mais aussi
sur le plan social qui est un des
éléments peut-être les moins évidents de
la politique qui est menée ces dernières
années et je veux parler notamment des
problèmes du logement nous partageons
évidemment j'allais dire des
préoccupations très fortes sur le
problème du logement et en particulier
sur la nécessité de redonner aux élus
locaux la main sur le logement et en
particulier sur le peuplement parce que
on l'a vu au moment des émeutes du mois
de juillet c'est indispensable que les
élus puissent reprendre la main au moins
en partie sur ce sujet je je veux parler
aussi de la dépendance nous sommes dans
un pays qui vieillit la dépendance c'est
le corollaire des retraites et nous
avons tout à faire dans ce domaine c'est
un sujet qui se promène de quinquena en
quinquena et nous avons à agir sur les
problèmes du 5e risque et puis Jean-Paul
vient d'en parler à l'instant c'est le
levier fiscal parce que faire des
économies c'est pas un but en soi il est
nécessaire de faire des économies on a
3000 milliards de dettes et 150
milliards de déficit annuel à l'évidence
faut faire des économies mais il faut
aussi utiliser le levier fiscal et nous
partageons avec le groupe du MoDem à
l'Assemblée nationale et avec Jean-Paul
évidemment la même préoccupation qui
consiste j'allais dire à vouloir taxer
non pas pour le plaisir de taxer mais
simplement mettre un ha sur des profits
qui sont excessifs on peut pas avoir
d'un côté 9 millions de gens qui sont en
état de précarité et voir de l'autre
côté des entreprises qui font des
profits insensés parce qu'il bénéficient
des circonstances du moment donc
je crois que cette dimension là c'est
nous qui devons la porter parce que il y
a une politique qui est libérale qui a
ses effets et ils sont positifs mais il
faut se voler social et c'est au modemme
à l'Assemblée et à l'Union centriste au
Sénat de porter cette préoccupation là
et puis la dernière chose le troisème la
troisème observation que je voudrais
faire et là aussi c'est dans l'ADN de ce
que nous portons ensemble les uns et les
autres que ce soit modem ou à l'UDI et
tous ceux qui nous sont proches c'est de
regarder bien sûr les Européennes de les
préparer mais aussi d'avoir la
perspective des présidentiells parce que
ça ne sera qu'une étape parce que au
fond du fond notre engagement c'est quoi
c'est d'éviter qu'en 2027 il y ait à
choisir entre Monsieur Mélenchon et
Madame Le Pen et si nous ne voulons pas
avoir affaire à ce dilemme terrible il
faut que nous nous organisions il faut
que nous nous y préparion et une des
premières étapes c'est bien sûr
l'élection européenne et nous y
prendrons toute notre part mais je crois
que ça doit être l'objectif suprême qui
est le nôtre c'est d'agir pour éviter
que Madame Le Pen devienne présidente de
ce pays et je crois que c'est quasiment
le le fondement même de notre engagement
alors s'il y a quelque chose à faire ça
sera de se préparer et se rassembler
pour éviter le moment venu à avoir à
choisir dans ce dilemme de terrible et
je
[Applaudissements]
dirais
comme le temps est compté et que je vois
mod Gatel qui s'apprête à me succéder à
la tribune je voudrais dire simplement
comme on dit dans le Béarn Yes We
Can
[Applaudissements]
voilà